[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Fabien Roussel bonjour bonjour vous
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous député
du Nord secrétaire national du Parti
communiste on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview avec la
presse régionale représenté par
Christelle mertrand du complat des pêche
bonjour bonjourian bonjour Fabien Rous
bonjour on va évidemmentement parler du
discours de politique général de Gabriel
Atal auquel vous avez assisté hier
Fabien Roussel si vous deviez le le
résumer en une phrase ça serait
laquelle un discours qui culpabilise les
Français c'est comme ça que vous l'avez
vécu bah oui s'il y a des s'il y a du
chômage c'est à cause des chômeurs s'il
y a de la pauvreté c'est à cause des
bénéficiaires du RSA et s'il y a des si
on arrive pas à trouver des médecins
c'est à cause des Français qui prennent
trop de rendez-vous et qui viennent pas
bref bah c'est pas un peu caricatural ah
bah c'est ce que j'ai entendu
excusez-moi ENF si ça va mal c'est à
cause de nous c'est pas de sa faute
c'est comme la smicardisation de la
France il y a le nombre de smicard est
passé en France de 12 % 2017 quand
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au pouvoir à
plus de 17 % aujourd'hui c'est quand
même pas de notre faute hein c'est quand
même un petit peu le résultat de leur
politique
donc les Français ont bien du mal à
joindre les debouts à élever leurs
enfants à payer le facture mais c'est
toujours notre faute et ça ça commence à
bien faire alors hier vous avez dit
c'est pas Gabriel hatal c'est Gabriel
sachur on est quand même loin de l' po
tax qui a été euh l'un des qui a valu la
le départ de la première ministre
britannique vous forcez pas un petit peu
le trait sur Gabriel Thatcher mais euh
ce qui m'a marqué dans le discours qu'il
a prononcé hier c'est qu'il est allé
même plus loin dans le discours libéral
que celui auquel je m'attendais par
exemple ils ont décidé ça je l'avais pas
vu arriver ils ont décidé de déshabiller
la loi SRU la loi qui impose aux
communes de construire 25 % de logements
sociaux pour pouvoir répondre à la crise
du logement qu'elle là dans notre pays
et si ces communes n'atteignent pas ces
25 % elles payent une amende et il y a
aujourd'hui des communes plutôt tenues
par la droite et des communes très
bourgeoises qui qui sont fiers même de
payer cette amende c'est c'est c'est un
coup de canif dans le contrat
républicain alors il a dit qu'il fallait
intégrer dans ce calcul les logements
intermédiaires qui bénéficient au classe
moyenne ou enfin plus qu'au classe
moyenne ce sont des logements qui ne
sont pas subventionné justement pour
pouvoir accueillir des familles des des
des classes modaises des classe
populaire des travailleurs des aides
soignantes parce que c'est ça
aujourd'hui hein et bien voilà ils
n'auront plus l'obligation de construire
ces 25 % de logements sociaux pour ces
familles-là et mais ça c'est vous vous
rendez compte la crise du logement qu'il
y a dans notre pays et c'est c'est c'est
c'est je sais pas où ils vivent l'année
dernière en 2022 en 2023 la France a
construit entre 80000 à 90000 logements
sociaux quand l'objectif était d'en
faire 150000 on est en dessous de tout
il y a il y a plus de 2 millions de Fran
fr qui sont en attente d'un logement
social et qui et et on en a pas parce
qu'ils n'en construisent pas et c'est
pas de la faute des bailleurs c'est de
la faute de l'État qui a augmenté la TVA
qui l'a fait passer de 55 à 10 qui leur
ponctionne au bailleur plus d'un
milliard tous les ans et donc forcément
les bailleurs sont étranglés moi je le
vis dans dans ma commune de
saint-armment Les eau dans les communes
des villages ma circonscription les
bailleurs ont bien du mal à programmer
des opérations de logement donc là avec
les annonces de Monsieur Atal et c'est
pour ça que je vous dis que c'est un
discours qui est très libéral c'est
qu'il est allé plus loin sur des
secteurs comme le logement qui était
déjà en crise qui est un des secteurs
qui doit faire le plus d'efforts
notamment pour le défi climatique
c'est-à-dire la rénovation thermique des
logements et cetera mais allez hop c'est
c'est l'économie de marché qui va
prendre le pouvoir et je trouve que ça
c'est sur ce sujet là du logement c'est
extrêmement grave lui a axé son discours
sur les classe moyenne en disant c'est
elles qui ont besoin aujourd'hui qu'on
s'intéresse à elles et qu'on les qu'on
les aide est-ce que la gauche dans les
années précédentes n'a pas un peu oublié
ses classes moyennes ce qui a nourri par
exemple une partie du mouvement des
gilets jaunes bah vous savez moi je suis
secrétaire national du Parti communiste
français ouais et donc je rends compte
de la politique et des propositions que
mon parti a défendu ces dernières années
et j'ai été élu en 2018 à peu près en
même temps que Emmanuel Macron lui est
devenu président de la République donc
j'ai vu ce qui s'est passé ce qui se
passe dans mon pays depuis cette période
et ce que nous nous avons défendu ce que
nous voulons pour le monde du trava pour
les retraiter pour la jeunesse de notre
pays nous nous battons nous pour que
l'ensemble des salaires soit indexé sur
l'inflation et que pour tous les
Français qui travaillent puissent vivre
de leur travail nous faisons de ce
combat contre la vie chère et pour la
dignité du monde du travail le cœur de
notre projet de société reconstruire une
France du travail où chacun puisse vivre
de son métier de son travail en tenant
compte de l'ancienneté des compétences
on a un gouvernement qui depuis cette
date depuis 2017 depuis qu'Emmanuel
Macron est arrivé qui a complètement
déshabillé
la France du travail il a précarisé le
travail il a smicardisé le pays on est à
plus de 3 millions de personnes vivant
au SMIC et et et et ceux qui sont
au-dessus du SMIC ne voient pas leur
salaire augmenter nous avons aujourd'hui
des Français qui doivent travailler 2
ans de plus avec la réforme de retraite
passé à 64 ans nous nous avons combattu
ces mesur d'injustice sociale et nous
avons voulu nous avons fait des
propositions pour reconstruire une
France du travail et ces propositions
ont été balayé d'un vers de main et le
bilan il est là aujourd'hui sans parler
de notre agriculture mais je pense qu'on
va on va y revenir en on a un pays qui
est complètement passé à la moulinette
des politiques libérales pardon mais sur
le SMIC il va il est allé exactement
dans le sens de votre discours il a dit
qu'il fallait des smicardiser la France
que on avait le le le trop le record en
tout cas par rapport à nos voisins qu'
avait trop de gens qui étaient proche du
SMIC et qu'il fallait changer tout ça
est-ce que là là-dessus c'est un bon
message mais c'est quoi le message il
fait le constat du bilan de sa poli oui
mais que du coup il fallait faire
évoluer les salaires proches du SMIC
quand il dit desicardis la France c'est
ce que ça veut dire il faut il faut il
faut il Aak foc hein c'est c'est quoi
concrètement qu'est-ce qu' met sur la
table est-ce que vous avez entendu
quelque chose sur le constat vous êtes
d'accord enfin le constat c'est nous qui
le faisons vous avez entendu la campagne
que j'ai lancé il y a quelques semaines
où j'ai invité les Français à nous
envoyer leur fiches de paye que je vais
porter à Matignon samedi 3 à 13h je
serai reçu à Matignon pour montrer les
par par son directeur de cabinet pour
pouvoir montrer l'ensemble des fiches de
paye que j'ai reçu de toute la France et
je vais les j'ai rencontré Gabriel hatal
jeudi dernier je lui ai dit que je
porterai tout ça et il ver et donc je
vais lui montrer des fiches de pay où
les gens sont au SMIC ou au-dessus du
SMIC oui où l'ancienneté n'est pas prise
en compte donc j'ai par exemple une
caissière d'une grande surface qui
depuis 35 ans est à 1550 € d'accord
c'est au-dessus du SMIC qu'est-ce
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
pour cette personne pour C cette salarié
est-ce que le SMIC va est-ce que son
salaire va augmenter est-ce que
l'ancienneté sera prise en compte j'ai
rien entendu dans ses propositions il
fait un constat le constformer le
système et que ça sera fait dès le
prochain budget oua non mais réformer le
système oui ben nous on demande de le
réformer le système on demande d'indexer
les salaire sur l'inflation on demande à
ce que l'ancienneté soit prise en compte
on demande à ce que les compétences soi
aussi prise en compte j'ai reçu une
fiche de paye d'une chercheuse bac + 8
bac + 8 c'est plus qu'ingénieur bac + 8
8 ans d'ancienneté 2700 € net ça ne paye
pas les compétences et après on s'étonne
que nos jeunes cerveaux s'en vont à
l'étranger et aux États-Unis mais ils
sont pas rémunérés à la hauteur mais il
appelle aussi les entreprises à le faire
dans les négociations de branche il dit
qu'il exclut aucun moyen pour au final
parvenir à desardiser la France pour
vous c'est du vent mais c'est des
paroles des paroles des paroles c'estida
qui est qui est à matigon excusez-moi
mais je n'ai rien entendu de concret
qu'est-ce que les Français vont retenir
de son discours hier soir est-ce qu'ils
vont s'en sortir avec plus d'argent dans
le porte-monnaie est-ce qu'ils vont
avoir gagné plus rien il y a eu des
choses concrètes zé si
allez les a les aesh vont être pris en
charge par l'État pendant les les heures
de midi le périscolaire oh là là ça ça
la
la la gauche le demander il nous a
entendu ça a concerné c'est bien pour
les avessages tant mieux et pour les
maires qui payaient parce que l'État ne
voulez pas payer sur la fonction
publique la prime au mérite ça va quand
même faire permettre d'augmenter les
salaires alors là alors ça ça si c'est
pas de de de la politique à la toucheur
la prime au mérite pour les
fonctionnaires ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que non non ça veut dire que
Monsieur hatal considère que les
fonctionnaires ne sont pas méritants
hein ça veut dire ça le message ils sont
pas
mér et ensuite ou bah si Ben s'il faut
récompenser les fonctionnaires il faut
augmenter leur point d'indice qui a été
gelé pendant plus de 10 ans la réalité
c'est que eux aussi dans la fonction
publique les salaires on é gelé de
combien de combien bah 2 et demi ils ont
perdu 10 10 10 points et ils ont laissé
augmenté de 2 et demi donc ils étaient
gelés depuis François Fillon il P pas
reprocher à Emmanuel Macron de pas avoir
dégelé depuis ouais d'accord en é Dégé
par la gauche on est loin de ah bah
c'est oui mais c'est et ça ne vous aura
pas échappé que nous avons contesté la
politique de François Hollande qui a
gelé le point d'indice qui a supprimé la
demi-part des retraités qui a fait du
mal lui aussi au porteemonnaie des
Français maintenant j'en viiens à la
prime au mérite alors là je veux
voir là je veux voir qu'est-ce qu'il va
dire au policiers pour être méritant
qu'est-ce qu'il va dire aux infirmière
dans les hôpitaux publics pour être
méritante qu'est-ce qu'il va dire aux
enseignantes pour être méritante ça va
être quoi de faire des heures sup ils en
font déjà au aux infirmières ça va être
de travailler plus ils travaillent ell
travaillent déjà beaucoup plus et c'est
pour ça que beaucoup d'entre elles
démissionnent au policiers à qui on va
demander d'être mobilisé pendant les je
ça a déjà été plus ou moins misise en
place oui mais non mais enfin vous vous
rendez compte un petit peu de ce que ça
veut dire pour les dans les têtes de ces
millions d'hommes et de femmes qui pour
beaucoup les fonctionnaire je pense
notamment à celles qui sont en
catégorisé dans la fonction publique
d'État ou territoriale
territorial les catégories C c'est 1500
1600 € net par mois à travailler 39 he
mais on se dit ça pe permettre de
l'augmenter c'est ça mais à partir de
quelle base le mérite c'est quoi ça veut
dire quand on est malade de venir
travailler ça veut dire de faire des
heur su ça veut dire de sacrifier ses
vacances mais dans c'est ça quand on ne
rest c'est ça ne pas respecter le monde
du travail c'est ça dire au français
c'est de votre faute si ça va pas vous
travaillez voy pas assz donc on va vous
mettre un petit coup de chlag pour
pouvoir gagner un peu plus et sinon vous
continuerez à manger votre pain noir
rester dans ce
domain Premier ministre il a dessiné les
contours d'une réforme de l'assurance
chômage aussi vous êtes inquiet aussi
par rapport à ça ben ça fait partir ça
fait partie du du discours culpabilisant
que j'ai entendu il y a 7 % de taux de
chômage dans notre pays et il y a des
entreprises qui ne trouvent pas à
recruter donc l'équation est simple
c'est de la faute des chôurs qui se
complaise dans le dans le chômage comme
s'il se complaisait dans le chômage et
donc on va réduire encore les indemnités
il y a aujourd'hui à peu près moins de
la moitié des personnes au chômage qui
perçoivent des indemnités déjà déjà ça
veut dire que il y en a moitié qui ne
les perçoivent pas ces indemnités
chômage donc ils n'en profitent pas du
système ils ne touchent rien ils ont été
ils sont sortis des chiffres du chômage
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire de plus il va
les les les forcer à aller travailler
comment il n'y a pas de politique
incitative qui tire par le haut la
France qui tire par le haut les Français
et le monde du travail nous avons autour
de notre pays des pays comme la Belgique
comme l'Allemagne comme le Luxembourg
comme la Suisse où les salaires où les
salaires minimum sont beaucoup plus
élevés que ceux des français où le SMIC
les salaires l'ensemble des salaires
sont indexés sur l'inflation comme en
Belgique ce sont des pays qui
grandissent et qui produisent plus de
richesse parce que le travail rémunère
la France fait le choix inverse c'est de
tirer par le bas du coût du travail et
d'apauvrir les travailleurs les Français
et la France au final ils ont fait le
choix de défiscaliser le capital et
d'appauvrir le travail et c'est ce que
nous subissons depuis au-delà de la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron mais c'est
le coup d'accélérateur qui a fait
Emmanuel Macron c'est de défiscaliser le
capital et de de de de de ne pas
rémunérer le travail à la hauteur de ce
quel lien vous faites entre la
rémunération du travail et les gens qui
restent au chômage ça veut dire que des
gens restent au chômage parce qu'ils ne
sont pas assez bien rémunérés bah
écoutez quand je rencontre les agents de
Pôle emploi de ma circonscription euh où
il y a un taux de chômage qui est un peu
plus bas que dans la moyenne à saintaman
les EAU notamment on fait une politique
pour attirer les entreprises et cetera
euh mais on a on a un taux de chômage
qui est autour de 5 6 % on a des
entreprises qui ont du mal à recruter
mais dans des secteurs euh où c'est
difficile et où les salaires restent bas
je pense à la restauration quand on doit
travailler euh 3h le midi rentrer chez
soi et retravailler 4h le soir rentrer à
minuit pour 1400 ou 1500 € nets il y a
quand même un problè il y a certaines
personnes qui font le choix de rester au
chômage parce que ces euh métiers ne
sont pas assez bien rémunérés mais mais
complètement parce qu'il ils en vivent
mal j'ai rencontré dans ma permanence
une jeune femme de quatre enfants et ça
c'est un sujet les mamans isolé les
mamans isolées une jeune femme de avec
qure enfants qui s'inscrit pour faire
une formation pour être chariste pour
travailler dans les entrepôts courageuse
madame et bien elle a perçu pendant et
elle est fière parce qu'elle a eu son
casses elle a eu son diplôme elle a
perçu 700 € de salaire pour faire cette
formation 700 € par mois pour suivre
cette formation pendant cette formation
elle a mis ses enfants à la cantine et
elle doit aujourd'hui payer 300 € de
cantine pour ses enfants elle m'a dit
j'ai pas encore reçu la garderie parce
que pour faire cette formation elle a
mis ses enfants à la cantine et elle
vient me voir en me disant comment je
fais pour payer c'est concret ça enfin
si on veut inciter les gens à s'inscrire
dans une démarche où on retrouve où on
renoue avec le travail un projet
professionnel où on va se former on doit
payer la formation comme un un emploi
permettant de vivre on doit aider les
mamans isolées à pouvoir mettre leurs
enfants à la garderie à la cantine sans
que ça leur faire per perd beaucoup de
de de salaire c'est c'est ce sont ils
vivent hors sol ces ministre ils ne
connaissent pas ces cas-là sur la
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État il a
confirmé qu'elle aurait bien lieu mais
par voie réglementaire c'est-à-dire que
le Parlement n'aura plus son mot à dire
est-ce que vous le
regrettez bien sûr ça continue mais
d'ailleurs il y a eu aucun mot sur le
493 mais le l'Assemblée nationale comme
le Sénat va être dépouillé de ses
prérogatives euh ça sur surprend pas
enfin je veux dire c'est dans leur
méthode au lieu de chercher à
construire des compromis pour trouver
des des le moyen de construire la loi
avec l'ensemble des parlementaires dans
la diversité de leurs opinions et on
regard des immenses défis qu'on a relevé
ils font le choix de la brutalité et de
décider seul et avec un gouvernement
enin excusez-moi enfin euh
entre des ministres qui cumulent des
entre les ministres qui cumulent des des
portefeuilles la santé et le travail
pour l'une l'éducation et le sport pour
l'autre pas pour longtemps bahici le
prochain remanimement oui bah mais vous
auriez souhaité rouvrir un débat sur
l'immigration parce que c'est ça si le
la réforme de laame était repassé devant
le Parlement
ben ce sont des
sujets qui méritent d'être débattus
parce que ce débat au moins permet de
nourrir le le des enfin l'opinion
publique aussi pour savoir ce qui se
passe la réalité des
chiffres les conséquences quand un texte
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale ou au
Sénat il y a toujours des des rapports
qui font des projections sur ce que ça
va coûter quel impact ça va avoir sur la
société sur le pays et donc la moindre
des choses c'est que on soit éclairé sur
des réformes qui sont importantes et
notamment sur laame moi j'ai en mémoire
cette magnifique tribune des médecins
qui qui sont les premiers à dire n'y
touchez pas puisque ça va mettre en
cause l'état de santé de du du peuple
des Français par ça porte atteinte à la
santé publiqueble l'ensemble de la
gauche est opposé à la réforme de laame
est-ce que vous allez avoir les moyens
de vous y opposer si ça ne passe pas par
le Parlement et quels peuvent être les
moyens de s'opposer à cette réforme vous
n'aurez pas votre voilà vous n'urez pas
votre Mo dire B non c'est c'est le prop
d'un régime autoritaire si vous voulez
que je vous dise mais non mais comment
on fait mais comment ils font les
agriculteurs pour se faire entendre
alors justement sur la crise
et quand et quand attendez excusez-moi
et quand moi au mois de septembre j'ai
dit parce que j'étais en colère de rien
voir arriver sur les salaires sur les
factures les factures de DF
d'électricité et que j'ai dit si ça
continue et pour se faire entendre on va
envahir les préfectures ou là là lever
de bouclier hein surtout non c'est pas
bien restez chez vous non non mais soyez
sages hein vous pourrez pas voter vous
aurez du 493 on va vous taper dans le
porte-monnaie mais restez chez vous et
et et fermez là je je je je je je crains
pour pour mon pays je crains pour la
démocratie et c'est bien pour ça que
j'appelle à un sursaut j'appelle à ce
que les
Français se se se mobilise et que là
aujourdielle manière de quelle manière
aujourd'hui on a une mobilisation des
agriculteurs qui est juste qui est saine
et qui est en plus fait de manière enfin
globalement très largement Pacifique
familial hein autour des barbecue sur
les autoroutes vois pas d'ailleurs
pourquoi ils ont peur de tous ces
barbecue autour de Paris c'est plutôt
sympathique et bien on pourrait tous y
retrouver on pourrait
avoir on pourrait avoir une mobilisation
populaire citoyenne autour de nos
agricultsensemble des Français aller les
soutenir sur les blocage j'appelle à la
convergence des colères parce que le
premier ministre hier n'a rien annoncé
de concret pour les français pour les
agriculteurs attendez mais en plus de ça
il confirme la hausse des factures
d'électricité à partir du 1er février la
hausse des franchises médicales et pour
les communes les impôts fonciers vont
aussi augmenter en 2024 elle doit
prendre quelle forme elle doit prendre
quelle forme cette convergence
descolèire pour vous qu'est-ce que vous
dites au français j'ai vu que le
syndicat CGT appelit lui aussi à ce que
les les salariés se mobilisent parce que
il ne voit rien venir dans les
négociations salariales et donc donc
c'est quoi greffe générale je sais je
pas dit ça ce que non mais non mais on
nappuie pas sur un bouton pour avoir la
greffe générale c'est bien pour ça c'est
bien pour ça que je vous dis que moi
personnellement moi personnellement et
nous les communistes français on appelle
à ce que les Français
s'unissent dans la diversité de de leur
profession de leurs opinions parce que
aujourd'hui on a besoin de peser contre
ce gouvernement donc quand je dis suniss
ça veut dire que si demain les
agriculteurs font le choix d'appeler les
Français à les rejoindre pour peser plus
sur le gouvernement il faut que nous
soyons prêts à y aller et je laisse les
agriculteurs et les organisations
syndicales décider de leur mode d'action
je l'ai toujours fait y compris sur la
réforme des retraites nous avons jamais
jamais étit au-delà pour leur dire
comment il fallait faire vous encouragez
un blocage de ringis par exemple je
souhaiterais je souhaiterais moi je
souhaiterais qu'on puisse tous se
retrouver pour que l'on puisse peser sur
ce gouvernement les Hauses des facture
d'électricité vont peser sur les les
exploitations agricoles ils le disent
aussi ajouter à ça la hausse des mutuels
enfin les mutuelles elles vont augmenter
de 10 % en
moyenne vous vous rendez compte le
catalogue que l'on pourrait faire des
mauvaises nouvelles pour les Français en
2024 alors qu'on a besoin d'air
d'oxygène de jours heureux comme je
milite depuis depuis ma campagne des
élections présidentielles parce que
c'est possible nous sommes un pays qui
pouvons qui pourrait passer un pacte
avec les français pour enfin se projeter
dans un avenir heureux est-ce que ça
veut dire que vous appelez concrètement
les militants du parti communiste par
exemple à aller soutenir les
agriculteurs sur Lesage vous le faites
déjà mais on le fait le fait nous sommes
présents on apporte à boire à manger on
nourrit les sur les points de blocage
les agriculteurs pour les aider à tenir
et à tenir bon et on est avec eux mais
il y a pas que nous moi j'ai vu j'étais
sur un point de blocage j'ai vu les
boulangers apporter les baguettes de
pain j'ai V VUR de Gabriel Atal hier sur
cette question de l'agriculture mais on
les agriculteurs eux-mêmes attendaient
des réponses plus concrètes au-delà des
dérogations qui ne sont que des
dérogations ils attendaient des mesures
concrètes concernant les traités de
libre échange alors Gabriel hatal il
peut les dénoncer les traités de libre
échamb mais enfin il faut qu'il soit
cohérent sont ses députés de sa
formation politique les ont voté entre
le Canada en 2018 le
C
ils les ont voté oui mais ils les ont
voté les autres leouton qui va venir de
nouvelle il vient pas tout seul il a VI
ét autorisé à revenir avec des des des
droits de douane nul il faut supprimer
il faut supprimer tous les traités de
libre échange ce que l'on peut mettre
concernant ces traités de libre échange
c'est deux choses un les clauses miroir
les clauses miroir c'est s'assurer que
dans le pays d'où vient le bœuf ou le
mouton il respecte les mêmes normes
imposées à nos agriculteurs ici et là je
mets au défi le ministère de
l'Agriculture d'envoyer des
fonctionnaires contrôler aussi durement
les les les producteurs de viande en
Argentine au Brésil que ceux en France
et la deuxième chose c'est que quand une
filière est menacée quand nous sommes au
bord de perdre notre souveraineté comme
par exemple dans la production de lait
on a perdu 800 850000 vaches on a perdu
850000 vaches dans notre pays et bien
quand on a une filière qui est en
difficulté on peut mettre en avant une
clause de sauvegarde en disant pour
cette filière stop stop basta on arrête
on protège notre filière parce qu'elle
est menacée par les traités de libre
échange et ça c'est dans la loi et nous
pouvons le mettre en re donc nous avons
des des moyens législatif mais Gabriel
il dit par exemple que les producteurs
laitiers ils exportent pour 4 milliards
est-ce que du coup ça va pas ils
exportent du lait en
poudre en donc ça va Pasir à la filière
laère de bloquer passe aujourd'hui c'est
que nos producteurs de lait vendent du
lait à 35 38 40 centimes du litre ils
consacreent des heures et des heures
pour traire les vaches les nourrir les
soigner et de l'autre côté il y a des
des industriels comme Lactalis qui eux
se font du beurre et alors dans les deux
sens du terme parce que d'abord pour
écrémer le lait ils font du beurre ils
sonont du beurre sur le beurre mais en
plus de ça ils se distribuent des
dividendes comme jamais le PDG de
Lactalis monsieur beignet est la 6e
fortune de France la 6e fortune de
France et son patrimoine entre 2017
quand Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au
pouvoir c'est aussi son bilan à Gabriel
hatal et et à Emmanuel Macron son
patrimoine il est passé de 8 milliards à
14 milliards il a presque doublé est-ce
que le patrimoine de nos agriculteurs il
a doublé dans la même période non et
c'est là où il y a une injustice énorme
c'est que la richesse faut notre pays
est riche la richesse que nous
produisons elle ne retourne pas à ceux
qui la produisent à ceux qui suent à
ceux qui travaillent à ceux qui à ceux
qui soigne la richesse elle est captée
par une minorité et c'est pour cela que
nous disons nous on a pas de problème
d'argent on a pas de problème de
richesse on demande juste non seulement
une meilleure répartition mais aussi de
pouvoir agir sur la manière dont on
produit pour pouvoir pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que l'on produise
sainement que l'on produise en France
que l'on produise en respectant
notamment les les nouvell règ que vous
allez sur les points de bclage pour
sououtenir les agriculteurs mais vous
tenez pas du tout le même discours
queeux eux ils disent stop les normes on
n' peut plus on ne veut plus de normes
du tout ce qui pas si c'est ce qu' c'est
ce qu'on entend un peu partout quand
même vous n'entendez pas la même chose
venez avec moi d'accord venez avec moi
ils vous disent pas stop les normes ils
disent que sur un marché européen bien
sûr qu'on a besoin de normes comment on
fait sinon avec des d'autres pays
agricoles qui produisent des céréales de
la viande et cetera on a bien sûr besoin
de normes équivalentes au sein de l'un
européne mais ce qu'ils disent ce qu'ils
disent c'est qu'il y a parmi ces normes
certaines sont util
mais il y a des normes qui sont
contradictoires les unes avec les autres
et il y a même la France qui décide de
sur
surtransposer certaines normes c'est ça
qu'ils disent mais ils ont raison
comment ça se fait qu'en Belgique est à
côté de chez moi dans le nord de la
France il ils ont moins de de nor pour
produire les pommes de terre que que que
chez nous à quelques quelques kilomè
après c'est ça qui est fou en rage et
ils disent pas qu'il faut plus de norme
ils disent il en faut il en faut faut
pour qu'on a tous les mêmes règles de
production mais ils disent qu'il y en a
un de trop dans certains domaines et de
deux qu'elles sont surtransposé en
France un dernier mot sur la motion de
censure que vous avez déposé avant même
le début du discours de Gabriel Attal
est-ce que c'est pas la preuve que c'est
un couple politique plutôt qu'une
réponse sur le MIN d'abord non mais
d'abord c'était c'était pour être
certain que l'on puisse pouvoir la voter
suffisamment tôt jeudi donc c'est une
question de délai sinon on les connaît
hein ils nous mettent la motion de
censure à minuit et puis puis ils sont
tranquilles euh mais on sera là et on
sera présent pour la voter et
d'ailleurs les députés qui feront le
choix de ne pas voter cette motion de
censure se rendront complices des
attaques sur le pouvoir d'achat des
Français la hausse des factures
d'électricité la hausse des franchise
médicale l'absence de mesures pour nos
agriculteurs l'absence de mesures pour
augmenter les salaires pour mieux
répartir les marges dans l'alimentation
et bien tout ça c'est au moment de la
motion de censure que l'on va pouvoir
enfin s'exprimer et dire il faut dès
maintenant dire non à ce gouvernement et
qu'il revoit sa copie merci Fabien
rouselci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité merci Christelle Gabrielle qui
est évidemment la Une de votre journal
ce matin on va regarder la Une de La
Dépêche le projet d'atal pour la France
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
Christelle on continue à parler de
Gabrielle et de la crise agricole dans
le club